former USA Gymnastics president Steve
penny says he didn't know he'd been
charged in connection with Larry
Nasser's sexual abuse case well penny
was arrested on Wednesday in Tennessee
after a Texas grand jury indicted him on
charges that he ordered documents to be
removed from the karoli ranch now that's
the training center when a sir a former
teen doctor abused some of the athletes
Penny's lawyer told CBS News he is
confident that he did nothing criminal
USA Gymnastics says it is fully
cooperating with the investigation and
quote will continue to do so to help the
survivors and our community heal from
this tragedy Jessica Howard is a former
Teen USA gymnast and board member who
says she was abused by NASA good morning
Jessica and thank you so much for
joining us so you worked with Steve
penny of USA Gymnastics you are on the
board with him for four years did you
exist see any of this type of behavior
Steve was a very intimidating figure he
was tall he was a big guy a little gruff
and you didn't want to cross him ever
if anybody brought up anything that
would you know disagree with him he
would shut it down very quickly and he
was also personally at like in the
hallway once he kind of got a little
close to me and like towering over me
made me feel very small and said why do
we even have your sport it doesn't bring
in any money and he was president of the
board he's president of USA Gymnastics
yeah and that was directly to my face so
like he was just that kind of guy and
his lawyer Jessica says he's confident
that he did nothing wrong are you
confident about that absolutely not
because he has been orchestrating this
from the very beginning he has been
worried as soon as I joined the board I
found out from my first meeting that all
they were interested in is money and
medals it was not about the athletes it
was about the athletes performing well
getting gold medals in Olympic and World
Championships that was their ultimate
goal and that brought in sponsors that
bought in money and that raised their
paychecks and that's really what
mattered to them and it left somebody
like me who was still an athlete mode
and
let's you know I was trying to please
them and do whatever I could to be the
best athlete I could and you know
improve my reputation and be you know
respected among them and I didn't ask
any questions and they did not share any
you know hint of a scandal with us in
which award you were also a victim of
Larry Nasser and I want to get your
reaction to the allegation that Steve
knew about this and waited five weeks
before first reporting it to the FBI and
allegedly 50 other girls had been abused
by Larry Nasser during that time period
what's your reaction to that you know
when I woke up to the news I felt a
couple of things almost exactly at the
same time I I felt relieved you know
that it happened but then this other
feeling washed over me and I was just
like it's about time like come on this
guy's been guilty as sin
from the very beginning he's known about
this since 2015 he has tried to silence
everyone who was involved at the very
beginning he is
since 2016 when the stories like started
becoming public he has tried to cover it
up he's paid people off he gave Larry
Nasser story that allowed him to
continue working with young athletes at
other gyms who he clearly did not care
about and one of them was as young as
eight years old but there were 50 to 60
victims I mean the numbers like change I
don't know what the correct one is but
young victims children that could have
been saved from sexual abuse I
he's been guilty as sin from the
beginning and you can't underestimate
you know the pain that he has caused
just by his lies
you talked also about the culture at USA
Gymnastics that he was part of it as
you've said what should happen to the
USA Gymnastics now I think from the
start of this and I I'm being I'm giving
them a lot of leeway by just saying from
the start of this situation because I
think it goes far far far far far back
but in the start of this situation they
have shown over and over and over and
over again that they are incapable of
dealing with this situation they cannot
make decisions that change policies that
protect athletes they are not athlete
centric they are metal and money centric
and they build machines they allow
emotional and physical abuse that makes
athletes perfect victims female athletes
perfect victims for sexual predators and
they are continually open to sexual
abuse and since then even since Steve
left there have been multiple examples I
can't even I can't even list them all
with Carrie Perry there in front of
Congress you couldn't even explain the
sexual abuse policy when a predator had
been called into USA Gymnastics and
somehow those predators stayed in the
gym and the leadership is still in limbo
now in the leadership is some limbo and
then they hired Tracy
Mary trait Mary Lee Tracy young and she
was a supporter of NASA and then that
didn't happen and then they just over
the weekend
hired Mary bono who was the heart of the
team that covered trying to cover up the
story for NASA I mean it's just like I
the complete oblivious detachment that
these people seem to have I can't
support and I think they've done it
themselves nobody else has been making
them make these mistakes
I think G certification is the only step
well if there's any way to rebuild USA
Gymnastics its voices like yours and I
think they were victims if they work
with the right people they work with the
right experts we have a shot at
rebuilding something strong so our
athletes can be safe thank you for your
bravery and for expressing your country
so many guys Jessica finicky just